ah
[Música]
y 6 millones de niñas no dan a clases 17
millones jamás irán a clases 6 misiones
se casaron este año 38 de ellas hoy 3 en
estos últimos 30 segundos una en este
momento
[Aplausos]
66 millones de niñas no van a clases 66
millones
piensen en esa cifra
es de locos pensar que 66 millones de
niñas no van a clase y sin embargo
existen compañías que están creando
cohetes que llevan a las personas a
marte o autos que se manejan solos
sin embargo decís no podemos mandar a
las niñas a clases
como puede ser que existan niñas que con
11 años sean forzadas a casarse 11 años
la de mi hija que recién se bajó no pone
empezar a pensar en ella casándose en
esta edad
sin embargo esa es la realidad de
millones de niñas alrededor del mundo
para poder frenar con esa demencia para
poder realmente generar un cambio hay
que hacer valga la redundancia un cambio
de mentalidad drástico a nivel mundial y
ahí es donde entra el problema uno dice
hay que hacer un cambio a nivel mundial
y panic ya veces es imposible es
demasiado podré cambiar mi entorno podré
cambiar mi casa pero mundial y te quedas
ahí pero saben que en una época también
era imposible que el hombre pisara la
luna
sin embargo ya sabemos cómo terminó de
eso
lo más lindo de que el hombre pisara la
luna es que dentro del equipo que
trabajó para que el hombre pudiera
realmente llegar a la luna había una
gran mujer no sólo una gran mujer sino
que una mujer negra que era marie
jackson rompiendo con todos los
estereotipos habidos y por haber una
matemática que gracias a sus cálculos
logró que algo tan imposible como llegar
a la luna fuera posible mujeres por las
dudas de que nos ha quedado claro si
ella no fuera suficiente tenemos a mala
la la joven activista
málaga con 15 años recibió un tiro en la
cabeza
15 años porque por defender la educación
de las niñas
cuando cuando volvía de la escuela que
su padre lideraba en su país natal en el
ómnibus rodeada de sus mejores amigas en
el último día de la escuela
nunca más volver a su país sin embargo
uno dice me pegaron un tiro a la cabeza
no puedo hacer nada más en la vida uno
cree que si imposibilita
a los 17 años recibió un premio nobel y
hoy en día recorre el mundo con su
fundación asegurándose que ninguna niña
pase por esa situación nunca más que
ninguna niña se quede sin educación
ahora bien vamos a hacer un pequeño
ejercicio piensen dos segunditos
si ustedes no hubieran tenido acceso a
la educación
hoy estarían dónde están
se los dejo ahí mientras seguimos está
dos tercios de las mujeres en el mundo
no saben leer o escribir
dos tercios
es demasiado yo sé que estoy con muchas
cifras pero es que una vez que uno logra
visualizar esas cifras si entiende la
importancia es cuando empieza a hacer
algo al respecto
ahora bien volvamos al ejercicio que les
dije antes
si ustedes
no hubieran tenido acceso a la educación
como tuvieron la posibilidad de ir a una
escuela hoy estarían en un stand hoy
serían quiénes son
quizás sí y es súper válido quizás no
pero la gran diferencia es que ustedes
tienen el poder de elegir quién ejercer
porque tuvieron las herramientas para
formarse y hacerlo
ahora no se olviden que el 66 millones
de niñas que no tienen esa chance 17 de
ellas nunca van a tener esa chance
y ahí es cuando yo me pregunto y cuando
creo que más me frustro
en qué momento decidimos que algunas
niñas si pueden tener acceso a ocasión y
otras no o aún peor en qué momento
decidimos que los varones y pueden traer
educación pero las niñas no
porque esa diferencia de género porque
si somos dos seres humanos algunos
tienen acceso a educación y otros no
se las dejo ahí también saber sobre eso
una vez noticias en facebook de repente
o bueno no sé mirando la tele
horrorizados quedamos todos de qué
espanto violaron esta niña qué horrible
hicieron trata de humanos con esta otra
o esta niña no tiene educación y todos
quedamos horrorizados y todos
compartimos los vídeos con el hashtag de
moda en el facebook y todos nos
solidarizamos y todos somos todos
y pocos hacen algo al respecto
porque porque normalmente cuando vemos
esas cosas pensamos que no nos suceden a
nosotros o que no nos suceden nuestro
entorno y que todo es super lejano en
países que incluso a veces se nos
complica hasta decir el nombre del país
pero saben que nada de esto es lejano
brasil nuestro país vecino que de hecho
de ahí vengo lamentablemente es el líder
latinoamericano de matrimonios
infantiles el líder
ocupa el cuarto lugar
a nivel mundial de casamientos
infantiles hay más de dos millones de
niños casándose en brasil 2 millones
chicos es como agarrar tu uruguay y
mandamos a casarse casi está monada
cuando empecé a buscar material sobre
esta charla para ellos ya tenían bien
claro cuál era el tema que quería tocar
pero si quería venir con datos y
estadísticas reales y empezó a caer en
cuenta de las cifras y los números
queden paralizadas o sea no acreditó los
repasaba lo repasa decía esto no es real
no puede ser la realidad del día a día
no puede ser que no estemos haciendo
absolutamente nada para cambiarla
y ahí un poco me puse a pensar en cuáles
son las excusas que tenemos nosotros
cuando decimos no estamos haciendo nada
para cambiarla
no tengo plata para adornar una
fundación para ayudar no tengo tiempo no
sé ni por dónde empezar
les voy a proponer algo empecemos por la
educación que es lo más sencillo y que
está al alcance de cada uno de nosotros
por la educación formal en la escuela
por los maestros por los profesores por
todos aquellos que nos educan día a día
pero por sobre todas las cosas por vos
por mí por él por ella por cada padre
tío prima sobrino el familiar que
quieran que rodee a esos niños
es muy muy muy fácil
y lograr cambiar esto
para que se hagan una idea por cada año
que una niña va a clases
sus ingresos adultas aumentan hasta en
un 20%
dicho de otra manera el que no se eduque
de niña no solo la está limitando
durante su niñez en lo que es aprender
en lo que sociabilizar en lo que es
generar vínculos sino que el de entrada
ya le está diciendo que de adulta no va
a estar en igualdad de condiciones que
los hombres que llevan adelante el país
por ejemplo
desde niña siempre permanentemente nos
están diciendo no corras no saltes no te
subas es árbol que te vas a caer fíjate
la pollera por este bien
sé perfecta ya los varones que les dicen
andaba correo en suciedad en las trabas
de subida y bajada y embarrados
cuanto más embarrado venga al nene mejor
parece ser
me encanta pero cuando llegan a adultos
sucede que las mujeres no nos animamos a
arriesgarnos de las mujeres le tememos a
tirarnos y probar algo y que nos salga
mal porque está todo bien que no salga
del normal pero nunca generamos esa
cualidad de niños entonces hoy en día la
mayoría de los hombres que están al
poder ya sea de una empresa de un país o
de lo que sea bueno para que la
redundancia es hombre
sólo el 17 por ciento de las mujeres
están en cargos altos políticos
alrededor del mundo
no somos nada somos muy poquitas
y la igualdad de género es algo que se
enseña desde el vientre a partir del
momento en que te enteraste que estás
embarazada y tenés que elegir si azul o
rosado para el color del cuarto ya le
está cerrando porque azul o rosado
en donde se dijo que una nena sí o sí
tiene cosas rosado y un niño sigue azul
yo ya sé que este concepto está trillado
y que todo el mundo habla lo mismo pero
nunca está de más repetirlo las niñas
pueden usar azul pueden jugar con
autitos y los niños pueden llorar y
jugar con barbies y está todo bien
así que les pido por favor que cada uno
desde su lugar empieza a romper esos
estereotipos que tenemos
capaz que es abrumador capas que salen
de acá y tengo mucha información para
procesar puede ser
y cada uno va a aportar su granito de
arena desde donde pueda y yo no pretendo
que todos generen algo demencial pero si
cada uno de nosotros ponemos un poquito
de nuestro lado
vamos a lograr efectivamente un gran
cambio
yo desde mi lugar como madre y como
emprendedora intento hacerlo con mis
emprendimientos desde que tengo uso de
razón
primero fue conté dibujo que vino lo un
día eso es otra cosa escuchen a los
niños uno tiende a no darles mucha
pelota a los niños porque son niños
pero los niños son muy sabios muy
creativos y muy inteligentes no solo
inteligentes e inteligentes sino
emocionalmente inteligentes y tenemos
mucho para aprender de ellos
mi hija se y 5 años atrás llegó con un
dibujo que yo había hecho de un peluche
de ella se hizo el proceso inverso
y con el afán de que ese dibujo cobrará
vida yo podría perfectamente haberlo
dicho aguardar qué hermoso dibujo suerte
en pila vamos a la cama pero no
yo busqué la manera de hacérselo
realidad sin querer queriendo pasó a ser
un emprendimiento pero todo nace de las
ganas de demostrarle a mi hija que no
hay imposibles
que puede lograr lo que se proponga
la gorda fue creciendo y un poco con
ella mi emprendimiento porque una madre
acompañe a su hija en su crecimiento sus
necesidades fueron cambiando un poquito
y me empezar cuenta que no tenía muchos
modelos de grandes mujeres a seguir que
fueran enseñados en la escuela por
ejemplo que les contaran se mira que lo
puedes hacer mira frida kahlo mira mal a
la mira marie curie tengo una lista
enorme
entonces dije voy a crear otro proyecto
no solo para mi hija sino para todas las
niñas del mundo y creé libro rebels o
pequeñas rebeldes si les gusta en
español que es una colección de muñecas
de peluche inspirada en grandes mujeres
que hicieron historia
entonces tenés a minimal a la mini todos
tienen la idea es que las niñas las vean
se identifiquen se sientan empoderadas
sigan yo puedo ser una científica
yo puedo llevar al hombre una versión a
la luna sólo llevo a júpiter
yo no tengo límites
tenemos que poder transmitirles esa
rebeldía
tenemos que tener mujeres rebeldes que
vayan en contra de todo lo previsto que
se hagan valer tenemos que tener hombres
que entiendan que mujeres y hombres
somos lo mismo que un género no es mejor
que el otro y que un género no te al
derecho a usar el otro como material de
intercambio
cambiar la realidad depende en la
educación de la igualdad de género
muchas las historias de esas niñas de
brasil
que se tuvieron que casar son en base a
situaciones de violencia doméstica o de
maltrato
y ese fue el resultado para ellos del
casamiento
entonces es muy fácil evitar eso
eduquemos eduquemos desde casa eduquemos
en valores que ambos géneros hagan las
camas que ambos géneros consiguen que
ambos se eduquen que ambos lean que
ambos estén hambrientos de poder que
ambos sean niños
hay 66 millones de niñas en este mundo
sin acceso a educación 66 millones de
niñas dependen de nosotros y vos qué vas
a hacer por ellos
ah